إنها مستشفى رائدة عالميًا
مع جميع المعدات المتطورة ، فهي
رائدة في الكثير من الأشياء التي
نقوم بها في البداية ، حيث يقوم هذا
المستشفى المتخصص في دبي بتوسيع
حدود الرعاية الطبية والمعرفة ولكن
لكي تتم رؤيتك ، يجب أن تكون
لطالما لعب نوع خاص جدًا من الجمال الصبور
دورًا مهمًا في
دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
ولكن بفضل عودة ظهور
سباقات الهجن التي أصبحت
تجارة بملايين الدولارات ، يوجد
الآن أكثر من 400000 من هذه
الحيوانات الفريدة في الإمارات العربية المتحدة.  افتتح مستشفى Camel Hospital
أبوابه في عام 2017 للمساعدة في
العناية بهم ، فهو مستشفى مناسب به
جميع الأقسام الصغيرة من
نوعها في العالم ، حيث
يمكننا استقبال 20 مريضًا في وقت واحد ،
ونعمل على توسيع جودة الهواء عندما
تكون هناك حاجة لإجراء عملية جراحية مثل هذا.
متسابق بطل مصاب بقدم مصابة ، هناك
غرفتان للعمليات المتخصصة
لدينا جمل ، وهذا كيف أن الانتفاخ به
علامات الإصابة بالعدوى ، الإبل فريدة للغاية
من نواح كثيرة لذلك  لا
تتفاعل بالضرورة بنفس الطريقة التي تتفاعل بها
الكثير من الحيوانات الأخرى ، فالكثير من الإبل
التي نراها تتسابق على الإبل ، لذا فنحن
نتخذ إجراءات جراحية من الخيول
التي تتبناها ، ونقوم بتغييرها
لتناسب الإبل التي نراها.  إعادة القيام
بإجراءات جديدة تمامًا
لم يتم القيام بها من قبل وهذا
تطور مثير حقًا في
عالم الطب البيطري يمكننا بعد ذلك
نقله إلى بلدان أخرى لمحاولة
تحسين رفاهية الإبل في أي مكان آخر
والقدرة على التحمل والرعاية البيطرية
[موسيقى]
بعد عملية استمرت ساعتين
تم نقل مريض اليوم للتعافي ، لدينا 20
قلمًا هنا ولدينا 12 قلمًا آخر
قيد الإنشاء في الوقت الحالي
في اليوم التالي لنفاد الصبر بعد خضوعهم
لعملية جراحية ، وهذا هو المكان الذي يتلقون
فيه الرعاية العلاج الطبيعي لإعادة التأهيل
بشكل مستمر لأننا "
دائمًا ما يكون معمل المستشفيات الموجود في الموقع ممتلئًا
يوفر الرعاية الصيدلانية
ويُجري أبحاثًا متطورة ،
ولم يتم إجراء الكثير من الأبحاث في
الإبل التي تم البحث عنها  ar تم إجراؤه في
صناعة الخيول وهذا هو السبب في
أننا نستفيد من هذا البحث لتطبيقه
على الإبل ، ولكن بالتأكيد كاميلي
الأنواع المختلفة وهدفنا هو
بدء بعض المشاريع البحثية التي نعرفها
عن الإبل.
المرضى لمدة 48 ساعة هذه هي الكاميرا
التي قمنا بتشغيلها في اليوم الآخر ، نحن
سعداء جدًا بالتقدم المحرز حتى
الآن ، لقد تغيرت لافتة اليوم
ويسعدنا كيف يبدو كل شيء أنها
مرتاحة على ساقها ثم يجب أن
تذهب  بالعودة إلى كونها جمل سباقات ناجح ،
ربما في الماضي إذا
لم تحصل على نفس المستوى من العلاج الذي
كانت ستنجو منه بالطبع ، لكنها
ربما لم تعد إلى السباق ، فأنت تشعر
بالرضا من القيام بأفضل
وظيفة ممكنة  يمكنك القيام به
وأنك تعلم أنك تحدث فرقًا